hello and welcome to the 12th PHP
tutorial in the last tutorial we left
off with a very basic array where it was
just you had different parts assigned to
this variable and you could call a
numerical number and receive you know
that part which in this case was a
string but it could be a you know an
injure or whatever so in this one we're
going to talk about an associative array
and the point of an associative array is
so you can actually like instead of
having it be this structured like this
is 0 this is 1 2 3 and so on you can
actually define the key in the array and
the key can be a numerical number or as
if there's any other type of number or
it can actually be string text so that's
not exciting let's get into it the
definition to it is pretty much the same
only let's call it something else we'll
call it cooler array and this time we're
gonna define it now if you recall let's
popovers
yeah it's still here remember how it
print our and printed this out for us it
said array and it gave all this stuff
this is actually how you will define
your associative array because what it
does is it actually prints out an
associative array for you and so the way
this looks is actually how you'll code
your associative array you'll choose the
stuff so instead of 0 we can put
anything we want in here let's just use
an example of like you're a teacher and
these are like students and their grades
for example so what you can do with an
associative array is later on reference
it and use it like I was saying like
earlier you use it much like a you would
use a Python dictionary you reference
for a key in value you know term in a
definition so let's just say you're a
teacher and you're going through this
array are you're adding stuff into the
array
say Jeff and Jeff got a 89 on his test
then we have or I'm sorry on a
semi-colon on a period either then we've
got Sally Sally got a 98
she was probably smartest one in the
class then we've got Kevin
Kevin's a little bit of a dunce
you got a 54 and Kelly guy a 79 so
there's our associative array now if you
wanted to call a part of that array like
we want to know yeah this list is really
long I can't remember what do you what
did Kelly get I got way too many
students so we just want to echo out
what did
echo cooler oh my goodness
cool array and the variable we want to
stuff in here is Kelly right we want to
know about the Kelly element so we want
to echo out the Kelly elements value
basically or really the Kelly key what
was for value so we'll come back over
here oh or refresh and oh yeah that's
right okay Kelly got a 79 so that's cool
it's nice that you can use it kind of as
like a way to categorize or to keep
track of like single elements at a time
you're like okay who did this person get
one at this person get what if this
person get but what if you want to build
like categories and put like maybe like
per each element of the array you want
even like wore arrays like some arrays
with an arrays and I know someone's
going to comment and say it and you know
what I'll just let someone go ahead and
comment say
hmm so I got a phone call I have no idea
where I left off somewhere in there I
was making fun of people that were gonna
no doubt say a reception but with that
sorry guys I ruined it for you anyway
as always thanks for watching and stay
tuned to the next video